westerns have been around for over a
century which means the genre is full of
pits and misses so how can you find the
very best of the best
well we've got you covered because these
are some of the westerns you need to see
before you die
clint eastwood director sergio leone
didn't invent the spaghetti western but
they pretty much perfected it with the
good the bad and the ugly
leone's eye for beautiful shots and his
ability to film brutal intense action
scenes
aided of course by enyo moriconi's
amazing musical score makes this film
stand out as a master class in creating
a simple
plot that means a great deal eastwood
plays the man with no name
although he's referred to as blondie
throughout the film he and two other
gunslingers are searching for a lost
stockpile of confederate gold
throughout the movie they keep running
into each other gleaning more and more
information about the whereabouts of
their prize until they finally arrive at
their destination
what follows is a three-way duel for all
the marbles with plenty of twists and
intense stare downs
spaghetti westerns are a great
demonstration of how our genre can adapt
and evolve over
time if you like the good the bad and
the ugly check out the other eastwood
leone team-ups
a fistful of dollars and for a few
dollars more all of these films are
classics that deserve a lot of praise
bravo it's one of the best buddy
westerns of all time
you can't go wrong with robert redford
and paul newman in butch cassidy and the
sundance kid
it's a movie where almost from the
get-go you can tell that disaster is
inevitable for our leading men
regardless it never gets old watching
the two struggle with their attempts to
escape the long-reaching arm of the law
all while cracking jokes and being
undeniably cool the story goes like this
butch is the charismatic leader of a
gang and sundance is his trusty
lieutenant
after a score goes wrong the two realize
they need to escape from the mobilized
lawmen who are after them
their solution is to flee to south
america along with sundance's girlfriend
where they'll be able to continue their
crime spree unimpeded
it's a fairly bare bones plot but the
star power of the two leads is magnetic
you really root for butch and sundance
to figure things out and find the life
they're searching for
and it seems like it just may happen
right up until it doesn't the finale is
a massive standoff against a literal
army of soldiers with a closing shot
you'll have a hard time forgetting
the late 1980s and early 1990s saw a
nice little revival for the western
genre with films like silverado and
dances with wolves
however one of the best of the bunch has
to be 1993's tombstone
it's a veritable who's who of some of
the biggest actors of the time
you've got val kilmer sam elliott bill
paxton and kurt russell among many
others
it's also immensely quotable mostly due
to a career defining performance from
kilmer as doc holliday
a movie sidekick who doesn't get nearly
enough credit you're probably seeing
double
i have two guns one for each of you
at first glance tombstone reads an awful
lot like a big dumb action movie but the
truth behind the film is actually pretty
fascinating
although it's obviously been dramatized
most of the events that take place in
the movie really occurred in the town of
tombstone arizona
there's the shootout at the o.k corral
wyatt earp's miraculous stand at the
creek ambush and the final ride to
destroy the cowboys
in fact some of the most ridiculous
aspects of the film are reportedly what
truly happened
some people might dismiss tombstone as a
pop western but don't fall into that
trap
just because it stars a lot of popular
90s actors doesn't mean it's a lesser
movie
regarded by many as sergio leone's best
spaghetti western once upon a time in
the west does a brilliant job of
matching impressive substance a leone's
well-known style
clint eastwood is nowhere to be found
here but we get the equally enigmatic
gunslinger known only as harmonica
played with steely intensity by charles
bronson it also features a master stroke
of casting against type
the normally lovable henry fonda choose
scenery as the despicable outlaw frank
once upon a time in the west is an epic
tale clocking in at almost three hours
and featuring a variety of interwoven
plots that help ramp up the intensity
and stakes as the film progresses
it culminates in a classic western
showdown between harmonica and frank
where it's finally revealed exactly why
harmonica is so help bent on taking down
the outlaw
the movie's got the classic style you
expect from sergio leone alongside
another timeless annual morticoni
soundtrack
it also boasts two extremely impressive
performances from bronson and fonda
so the next time someone claims that
westerns are just too simplistic
all you need to do is cue this one up it
would hardly be a list of must-see
westerns if john wayne didn't show up
once or twice
and the searchers is regarded as one of
his best the searchers is basically
about a man named ethan in his quest for
revenge
at the beginning of the film members of
ethan's family are murdered and others
captured by a comanche leader
ethan and a group of men go looking for
the captured girls the movie makes a
major point to focus on ethan's thirst
preventions at any cost rather than an
actual desire to do the right thing
this is most clearly illustrated when he
eventually finds his niece debbie who
decides she'd prefer to stay with her
captors and return with her uncle and
brother
in retaliation ethan threatens the
shooter stand aside martin
oh you don't eat if the goal of a
western is to provide a look at the war
going on inside the human psyche few
films do it as well as the searchers
the movie has influenced everyone from
george lucas to martin scorsese who was
inspired by the movie's plot
when developing his classic film taxi
driver starring robert de niro
the assassination of jesse james by the
coward robert ford has many strengths
including its impressive cast it
generally plays as a quiet
character-driven drama but it's
punctuated by loud violent acts that
keep the plot rolling
brad pitt and casey affleck star and it
also features sam rockwell and jeremy
renner
sadly this underrated film didn't
perform very well at the box office and
that's a real tragedy because it's a
genuine masterpiece
the film is based on a novel by ron
hansen and it follows james gang in the
events that eventually lead up to his
killing
as the members of his gang start to grow
distrustful and stab one another in the
back jesse keeps searching for men he
can trust
and puts his faith in the wrong person
one of the best aspects of the film is
how the aftermath of james's death is
handled
ford expects to receive a massive reward
and gain celebrity status for doing the
deed
instead he's reviled by anyone who knows
and the government never follows through
with the bounty
the assassination of jesse james does as
good a job as any westerner showing that
the glamorized ideals of the wild west
fall far
short of reality it may not seem cutting
edge nowadays but the wild bunch was a
fairly revolutionary film in 1969 both
for its cinematography and its subject
matter
it was nominated for several awards
across a variety of categories earning
accolades for its writing cinematography
and direction
the film was also controversial as the
violence was extremely graphic for a
mainstream film at the time
plus the main characters for the most
part are inherently unlikable
if they move kill them like many
westerns the wild bunch focuses on a
group of men trying to find their place
in a changing world
it tells the story of a gang of aging
outlaws who get entangled in several
difficult conflicts as they try to stay
alive and find their fortune
they wind up falling in with a mexican
general who they know they can't trust
but with options running low and the law
closing in they decide he's their best
bet
the tension builds throughout the movie
rarely getting a chance to defuse until
the end when a massive firefight brings
everything crashing down
the wild bunch stars hollywood legends
like william holden and ernest borgnine
and it's a great reference point for the
evolution from classic to modern western
and seriously that final shootout is one
of the most epic movie gun fights of all
time
unforgiven was clint eastwood's homage
to the films that jump-started his
career however this 1992 movie also does
a stunning job of telling a modern
western tale while staying grounded in
the real world
eastwood directed and starred playing a
retired gunslinger who agrees to do one
more job
and in the process has to face up to his
bloody past
i've killed one of my children
killed just about everything that walks
or crawled at one time or another
it's a familiar story but it works so
well and unforgiven because of
eastwood's impressive performance and
personal history
though he never actually left hollywood
eastwood feels like the retired
gunslinger
sliding back into the type of role that
made him famous and finding it just a
little too
easy as a director eastwood subverts a
lot of our expectations of the genre and
removes much of the romantic nature of
the old west
leaving an ugly dark scary place without
a lot of rules
unforgiven is a practically flawless
movie and it won several academy awards
including best picture and best director
released in 1939 stagecoach may seem a
little simplistic compared to the plots
of other legendary westerns
however it's a great way to see the
roots of the genre and how it's evolved
over the decades it's also one of john
wayne's best roles and we'd be remiss
not to include it here
at its core stagecoach is a simple story
of a group of very different people
forced to share space and trust in one
another
almost every character in the film is an
archetype the sex worker with the heart
of gold the reformed outlaw and the
drunken doctor to name just a few
but what makes stagecoach work so well
is how it throws these archetypes
together in different situations and
combinations
it isn't an overly action-packed film
it's more of a character drama that
weaves a tale about the mythology of the
old west
highlighted here and there by wild
chases and a few good shootouts
so if you want to experience a classic
western and see where the genre comes
from stagecoach is an excellent choice
many film fans consider high noon to be
the first true adult western one that
examines the morals of the old west and
explores the psychology of the men and
women living on the frontier
this 1952 movie also won several academy
awards including best actor for star
gary cooper
as for the film itself it's a tense
paired down western that explores the
nature of duty and morality
all through one man's desperate attempts
to stay alive high noon stars cooper as
marshall will kane a man who's getting
married and is about to retire but right
as he's preparing to set out for a new
life he learns that an outlaw he put
behind bars has been released and is
coming to town to exact revenge
his new wife played by grace kelly tries
to get him to leave but he refuses to
run
instead kane tries to round up a group
of men to help him fight unfortunately
he slowly learns that the town has
turned against him too cowardly to help
and fearful that they'll only get
themselves killed in the process
so kane decides to make a solitary final
stand at high noon when his nemesis
comes into town
compared to modern westerns high noon
may seem a bit slow but it features some
powerful and famous scenes like an
iconic crane shot showing how a lone
kane really is
whether you're a fan of westerns or not
this is a thoughtful and suspenseful
film that everyone should see
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie genres are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you